[Music]
if you got a robocall recently you're
not alone well it turns out last month
umail says americans received 4 billion
spam calls as john langler reports those
scammers are finding new ways to get
around those federal regulations
it's so frustrating the call is from a
number you think you recognize but it's
a scam there have been efforts to try
and cut those scam calls down but it
just hasn't been enough
joanna ganz says she wasn't cut off
guard when the phone rang the caller id
came through his chase bank the person
on the line said there was suspicious
activity on her account
gans says they told her she had to
transfer money out of her account to
stop it everything he said led me to
believe because of the way he spoke and
the exact exact verbiage that the bank
uses he had it down pat
turns out the call was a scam within
minutes gans was out more than twenty
five hundred dollars i
really never thought it would happen to
me i mean that's my rent and bill money
last june the fcc required all cell
phone carriers to adopt caller id
authentication technology called stir
shaken the goal was to prevent illegally
spoofed robo calls but since then the
number of robocalls getting through to
consumers has gone back to the level
from before the regulation
problem is the bad guys aren't sitting
still instead of just making up phone
numbers they're getting real phone
numbers and now their real phone numbers
are authenticated they look like they're
good and they get through alex quillissy
is the ceo of the robocall blocking app
umail he says technology like stir
shaken isn't enough to crack down on
spam calls you want enforcement to go
not only after the bad guys but some of
the carriers that are supporting them a
spokesperson for chase banks says gans
authorized the transfer so the bank
isn't going to return her money but a
reminder banks will never call or ask
for your personal information that will
only happen if you call them first john
langler live local now